ここからのテーマは、AIにおける原則、倫理、リスクです。
前の動画の中であった、生成AIは中で何をしているのか、といった仕組みの話に対して、こちらはですね、使ってもよいのか、ダメなのかを判断するための、いわば物差しの話です。
それでは、やっていきましょう。
まずですね、細かいルールの前に、なんで原則が理念から入るのか、という話をさせてください。
リュースというのが、大抵、先行してですね、進んでいくことが多いです。
生成はまさにそうですよね。
新しいAIサービスが日進月歩に追い出て、ニュースで毎日AIの話題が出てきます。
つまり、ルールというものは、かなり後追いで入ってくることがあります。
だからこそ、ルールが追いついていないグレーな場面では、何を頼りに判断すればいいのか、ということがわからないわけですね。
そこで聞いてくるのが、理念というわけです。
この図を見てください。
ピラミッド状になっています。
一番上が理念ですね。
これはですね、例えば人間第一ですよ、みたいな、そうしたことが入ってくるわけです。
その下に社会的な指針があって、各学会ですとかですね、いろんな組織の理念な指針があって、
そしてその下に技術的な指針や利用規約みたいなのが、いろいろと繋がっているわけでございます。
下に行くほど技術先行によってどんどん変わり続けますけども、
上の方はですね、安定して変わらない原則だったりするわけです。
なので判断に迷ったときほど、自分にとっての考え方であったりとか、
あるいは理念という部分をしっかりと見ていくことが重要かなというふうに思います。
この図が今回の動画で貫く全体像でございます。
では、その一番上にある理念とは、例えばAの場合、何なんでしょうか。
こちらのスライドに3つの理念を並べています。
これは、人間中心のAI社会原則と呼ばれるものです。
最上位の価値として、そもそも何のためにAIを使うのか。
以下の3つの価値を理念として尊重し、その実現を追求する社会を構築するべきだということで、3つとなっているわけでございます。
1つ目は人間の尊厳でございます。
AIに人を振り回されず、人間が中心になり続けるということです。
人間がAIをある意味道具として使いこなすような形で、人間の尊厳が尊重される社会を構築するということを考えています。
それから、多様性や法説についてです。
様々な背景の人が誰も取り残されないように、新しい価値を想像できる社会として、その道具としてAIが位置づけられているわけでございます。
それから、持続可能な社会ということで、恩恵を将来世代まで届けるということで、持続可能性も含めてですね、その追求のためにAIがあるといったことが書かれているわけでございます。
これらは、内閣府統合イノベーション戦略推進会議のですね、こちらのリンクから飛べますので、もしよければ読んでみてください。
この理念からですね、人間中心、透明性、公平性といった話が出てきます。
先ほどの3つの理念から導かれるのは、7つのAI社会原則でございます。
こちらは、日本の国の中で決めているものですので、場合によってはですね、他の国とはちょっとずつ違っていくわけなんですけども、
先ほどの理念を社会全体実現するための原則として書かれているものでございます。
人間中心、教育リテラシー、プライバシー確保、セキュリティ確保、公正な競争、公平性、説明責任や透明性、
そしてイノベーションということになっています。
この中でですね、人間中心であったり、教育リテラシーであったり、公平性、説明責任、透明性というね、
この3つの部分は研究にも大きく変わってくると言えます。
国が定めているこの7つの社会原則の価値はですね、学会や組織の倫理識審ともですね、かなり共通した場合は多いのではないでしょうか。
例えばこちらはですね、総務省のAIガイドライン比較表というものがありまして、それらのもとにですね、どういった内容があるかというものを書いたものでございます。
総務省の方、この7つになっていますが、例えばEUの方もですね、そうした形でかなり似たような
領域が入っているようでございます。
もちろんこの表の中にはそれ以外のいろんな価値もですね、含まれていて軸で書いてあるんですけども、
人間中心だとか、安全の部分だとかですね、通した部分は共通ですので、軸というものはかなり揃ってきたのかなという印象を受けています。
さて、先ほど出てきた人間中心、透明性、公平性というところで、ちょっと気になる点をご説明いたしましょう。
まずですね、透明性の部分です。
研究者の観点からこれはどういうことかというとですね、使ったら開示するということなんですね。
どこでどう使ったのかの記録やログが必要ですし、あるいはですね、投稿先であったり指導教員とかにですね、
AIこういうのに使いましたよって開示する必要がございます。
それから人間中心というところで最終的には人なんですね。
これはですね、逆に言えば、人間中心だから簡単になるというより、人間中心だから難しくなるわけなんですけども、
AIこういったというのは便利にならないわけですね。
生成にオーサーシップは認められていませんので、判断と責任は人が負うということになります。
それから公平性の部分なんですが、
右の図のようにですね、生成AIの出力を確かめてみると、こういうふうにバイアスが出てくるというふうに言われています。
その人の資料の中でですね、看護師さんという形でそれを入力すると、こういうふうに女性ばっかりになったということですね。
人間も生成AIの方もですね、双方がバイアスを何らかの形で持っているので十分注意する必要があります。
この3点というのは、研究での生成AIの際には常につきまとってくる原則というふうになります。
さて、原則の話はここまで締まりましたが、それ以外にもですね、リスクであったり知っておくべき点がありますので、それらを説明していきましょう。
一つ目は、権利侵害や知的財産権に関する注意点でございます。
例えばですね、こうした人格にかかる部分ですね。
例えば、肖像だったり、名誉基礎にならないようにしたりとか、そうした部分はかなり注意しなければなりません。
あとは、自分自身が詐欺に合わないように注意するというのもありまして、実はその自分のですね、ディープフェイクを作られたとか、なんか社長名義のディープフェイクが出てきたとかですね、いろんな問題があったりするようでございます。
他人の画像とか音声とかですね、無伝で素材がしないということは重要なのかなと考えます。
二つ目は著作権ですね。
これ重要なのは、学習段階と生成段階を分けるということでございます。
これ右の方に図がありますが、異教性、類似性、それ以外にですね、既存の著作物に類似しているかということでですね、類似しているなとなったらですね、
それが複製なのか、法案なのか、みたいな形で著作権侵害になるかもということでございます。
著作権者のですね、権利を不当に侵害する場合というのはですね、例外なく著作権の侵害になります。
権利を不当に侵害しない場合において、著作権者の権利を制限できる、権利制限規制としての例外というのがいくつかあります。
どちらかというとですね、例外の方を僕らよく覚えているわけですね。
つまり教育利用は引き起きしてもいいよだったり、引用してもいいよという話ですね。
先生にかかる部分はここなんですけども、先生の学習自体にAIを使うのは問題はないと、著作権上は認められているものでございます。
ところがですね、その出力がですね、既存作品に出たり、あるいはそれを売ったりしたらですね、その順でNGとなりますので、
その手間は十分注意する必要があるかなというふうに思います。
それから著作物を読み込んだ上でですね、読み込んだAIを他に配布するのはどうなのということなんですけど、
その場合はですね、この一番上の例外の部分、つまり、
著作物をですね、読み込んだAIを叩いて、著作物の中身が全部出てくるんだったらですね、
それは不当に侵害することになりますよね。
その場合には、十分注意しないといけないわけでございます。
それから、知財の面ですけども、AIは発明者にはなれません。
あくまで人に帰属します。
あと、生成AIのですね、出力物についてもいろいろと議論があります。
多くの場合には、それの利用者のものになるよというふうに書いている場合もありますけども、
そこら辺はですね、
場合によっては、帰属が定められた場合がありますので、十分にご注意ください。
ということでですね、学習に使うというところと、
何らかをですね、作って使うというのは別問題なので、
詳しくはそれらは動画4において扱っていきましょう。
それから、入力の部分です。
入力した情報に大丈夫ですか?ということです。
2つ落としはながらあって、
1つ目は個人情報と研究所の秘密です。
例えば、個人情報。
私が学生のレポートをAIに採点させたとしましょう。
入力が外部にわたってしまいますよね。
それが保存されて、学習に使われるとなるとですね、
個人情報は危ないのではないかということがあります。
それが例えば、名前を含んでいる場合だったり、
あるいはもっとプライベートな情報を含んでいる場合には、
非常に問題になりますよね。
個人情報保護法というものがあって、
かなり厳しく制限されているので、
その点は理解する必要があります。
そのためにはですね、オプトアウト設定であったり、
所属組織が契約したAIの利用だったり、
といったことは必要になるでしょう。
また、研究所の秘密、機密というものも、
かなりAIにはですね、デリケートな問題です。
未公開データだったり、
所属を頼まれた情報を外部のAIに入れるというのはアウトです。
あとですね、もし、何らか、東京だったり取る場合にはですね、
それが学習に疲れてしまったり、
何らかの物で外に戻ると、
公表扱いになってしまって、
機密性を失う恐れもあるんですね。
そのような機密保持や選手権がかかるような部分には、
十分注意しましょう。
AI関連の法制御なんですけども、
さっきのAI開発のですね、
様々な理念などがあったものが2017年ですけども、
2019年の方にはですね、
AI利活用原則みたいなものが出てきたわけでございます。
2020年になるとですね、
今度は総務省と経産省の間で、
そうしたAIの事業者、
AIが企業の中で用いられる場合などのですね、
様々なガイドラインというのが出来上がってきて、
2025年にAI推進法ができて、
2026年に生成AIのエージェントに対応したガイドラインが出てくるという形で、
様々なルールなどが整備されているというところでございます。
これはですね、国全体であったり、
皆さんが事業者となる場合のガイドラインなんですけども、
それらはですね、
十分に注意しつつ、
どこでそうしたものが更新されているのかをですね、
知っておくことは有用なのかなというふうに思います。
国のレベルでこんなに変わっているということは、
もちろん学科のレベルではもっと変わっているということなので、
その点も注意していきましょう。
ということで、この動画のまとめです。
理念、指針、リスクにおいて覚えてほしい重要な点について、
羅列したような動画となっております。
注意点としてはですね、
判断の物差しを持ちましょうということで、
理念に遡ったり、
あるいは指針の中で特に重要な人間中心、
透明性、公平性という部分をですね、
考えてあったり、
あるいは著作権、入力、
権利侵害にならないような使い方をしましょうということをお伝えしました。
それからですね、
行動指針の部分ではですね、
機密情報を入れない、
使ったかどうかを開示して記憶する、
それから責任は人になるよということも説明させていただきました。
それらですね、
いろんななんか、
覚えないといけないことが多そうな気もしますけども、
これらの注意点をですね、
まずは第一に守っていくというのが重要なのかなと思います。
それから、
かなり気をつけた部分になるかと思いますけども、
AI絡みの犯罪というのも出てきていると思います。
例えば、
何らかですね、
詐欺にAIを使ったというニュースがあったりとか、
あるいはですね、
性的な出力を行ったことによって、
犯罪になるような場合などですよね。
そうしたニュースで、
例えば大学生が捕まったみたいなことも出てくるわけですが、
皆さんも法令はですね、
十分注意しながら気をつけてほしいなというふうに思います。
ということで、
この動画の解説を終わります。
重要な動画ですので、
もう一度ぜひ確認していただければと思います。
ご視聴ありがとうございました。